entre moscou et kiev pékin joue les
équilibristes
d'un côté la volonté de ne pas fâcher
les partenaires européens avec qui les
relations commerciales sont beaucoup
plus importantes qu'avec la russie de
l'autre une relation privilégiée avec le
kremlin alimenté par une hostilité
commune envers les états unis et l'otan
soutient que pékin a réaffirmé
aujourd'hui
l'amitié entre les deux peuples et
solide comme le roc et les perspectives
de coopération future entre les deux
parties sont très larges
la relation chine russie et l'une des
relations bilatérales les plus
importantes au monde
habituellement très à cheval sur les
principes de la non ingérence et le
respect de l'intégrité territoriale
la chine n'a pourtant pas condamné
l'invasion russe en ukraine pas plus
qu'elle n'est mise en place de sanctions
contre le kremlin pékin se dit neutre
dans le conflit et a proposé de jouer un
rôle de médiation
un rôle j'étais pas des médiateurs
position de la position de la russie
mais
trois semaines avant le début de la
guerre vladimir poutine est reçu en
grande pompe par si jean ping lorsque
washington alerte sur les risques d'une
invasion imminente pekin les accuse de
jeter de l'huile sur le feu en
minimisant la menace les autorités
chinoises n'appelle pas immédiatement
leur 6000 ressortissants à quitter
l'ukraine les évacuations débuteront une
fois le conflit commencé et un étudiant
chinois sera alors blessé par balle les
autorités chinoises force est de se
rapprocher des ukrainiens auront attendu
ce 1er mars pour dire qu'il regrette le
conflit depuis pékin s'est engagé à
fournir de l'aide humanitaire à
l'ukraine